the ending of the original Night Court
tied up loose ends and featured a very
special guest spot from a jazz singer
known as The Velvet Fog here's how the
long-running sitcom left the airwaves on
a high note
Nightcore didn't have to wait three
decades for the events of its final
episodes to be undone it only took a
couple of weeks a stray unaired episode
and a hole in the NBC programming
schedule the series finale was a
two-parter titled opportunity knock
knocks which aired in a one-hour block
on Wednesday May 13 1992. the episodes
were promoted on NBC as the end of an
era and the episodes could not be
mistaken for anything but a Show's final
bow in both form and content yet on a
Sunday night more than two weeks later
what does NBC put on the air a brand new
episode of Night Court Sunday evening
programming on NBC in those years was a
hodgepodge of special events movies of
the week and sitcom reruns this
particular episode the 1992 boat show
was produced earlier in the season but
for whatever reason was knocked from its
planned premiere date directed by series
regular Charles Mack Robinson the
episode sees another one of Dan's social
climbing schemes blow up in his face
when he gets a fancy columnist out of
jury duty in exchange for a write-up in
the society Pages only for the reporter
to become entranced with raws instead
for anyone paying attention in 1992 that
extra episode of Night Court must have
been doubly confusing not only had the
previous two episodes been explicitly
billed as the end of the show but they
sent several of the series main
characters off into the sunset only for
them to pop up in court once again in
boat show as if nothing had happened
networks deciding to air episodes out of
sequence was of course nothing new at
the time and remains a questionable
practice even today when shows are far
more serialized in general than they
used to be plot wise the finale marks
the conclusion of two ongoing story
lines that were begun a few episodes
earlier these include Christine's
surprisingly difficult Congressional
race against a deeply unserious opponent
and Harry's decision to step down from
the bench and become a law professor
more importantly though the episodes
resolve emotional Journeys that have
been going on since nearly the first
episode from Harry and Christine's
season romantic relationship to Dan's
womanizing however all of this works
together to examine something even more
important the general feeling that the
night court is a somewhat melanchol
Valley Place full of people who got
there by happenstance and then never
left
as Harry weighs his options about
whether to leave the bench job offers
start pouring in first it is a
professorship at Columbia Law then a
partnership with a prestigious white
shoe firm then a possible judgeship in
the Superior Court then somehow a
sponsorship deal with Nike just when
things start to feel a little ridiculous
jazz singer Mel Tor May nicknamed The
Velvet Fog bursts into Harry's office
with an offer to go on tour and work on
his next album together as goofball and
non-sequitur as the show's humor could
be tormay didn't pop out of thin air for
the finale instead his appearance is the
Capper for dozens of jokes and cameos
going all the way back to season one
when tormay superfan Harry stage day one
person concert in his Chambers the 1980s
saw a wave of nostalgia for the big band
era that made stars out of young band
leaders like Winton Marsalis and Harry
Connick Jr while shining a fresh
Spotlight on survivors like Torme and
Tony Bennett Torme eventually guested on
the show nine times usually as himself
or as Harry's Guardian Angel though the
Aging crooner's role was always
tongue-in-cheek the show's appreciation
of him was absolutely genuine lead actor
Harry Anderson had been a lifelong fan
even before the series and spoke at
tormay's funeral In 1999.
as Harry weighs his options for which of
his many ludicrous job offers to take he
has written each of them down on an
index card tacked to a small cork board
he looks at the board pauses then turns
it away from the camera and the audience
he plays eeny meeny miny mo landing on
the decision to teach at Columbia and
when he turns the board back around all
of the cards now read the same thing
Colombia
unanimous folks
it's a fun little moment one of many
throughout the run of the series that
indulged Anderson's skill at sleight of
hand as a stand-up comic card tricks and
a general old-timey Vibe were Hallmarks
of his act and Stage Persona both before
and after night court his most notable
role prior to the series was as
small-time Boston con man Harry the Hat
on Cheers decked out in a fedora and a
wide 1940s style necktie Harry the Hat
was a welcome nuisance running small
games at the bar and often getting the
best of gullible characters like coach
and Woody like his contemporary Sam
Malone on Cheers John laroquette's
letters lawyer Dan Fielding is the kind
of character that wouldn't really fly
today the show ran long enough to
provide Dan with layers underneath his
boorish exterior and laroquet's
performance was so good that it was easy
to enjoy the character without fully
acknowledging his Worst Behavior Dan is
often the butt of the joke and his
schemes more often than not blow up in
his face but at the same time he mostly
gets a free pass for his callous
treatment to of women to its credit
though the finale reckons with Dan's
womanizing not once but twice and both
dramatic and farcical fashion an
opportunity knock knocks part 1 Dan's
plans to propose to a wealthy publishing
heiress are dashed when he discovers
that 25 years earlier he'd broken the
heart of his would-be fiancee's mother
played by Christine Belford Belford
delivers the Revelation in a stark
monologue while Arrow cat does some of
his best work in the series by just
listening opportunity knock knocks part
2 on the other hand gives Dan his
comeuppance in the form of a dream
sequence in which Every Woman he's ever
known packs into the courtroom to put
him on trial for his misdeeds with
Christine as his Defender and Ross as
his heartless judge
Richard moles breakout bailiff bull
Shannon is but one in a Continuum of
wacky sitcom characters who are not
quite of this Earth from Christopher
Lloyd's burnout Reverend Jim on taxi to
Kramer on Seinfeld the finale finds bull
in the grips of paranoia convinced that
he is being followed by strange men who
he believes might be aliens when we
finally see these aliens and opportunity
knock knocks part 2 they are a pair of
little old men from Jupiter Jupiter
Florida Meadows however at the end of
the episode we see that bull was right
all along these gentlemen really are
from Jupiter the planet and have come to
Earth to conscript bull for a mission of
Intergalactic importance they need him
to reach all the high stuff on their
shelves in an episode full of farewell's
bulls is perhaps the most permanent
disappearing from Harry's darkened
office in a flash of light and a roll of
the credits perhaps that finality is why
Maul has been less than enthusiastic
over the years about returning to his
most famous role so will you come
okay
within a year of the show's final
episode Harry Anderson Marky post and
John Larroquette were each headlining
their own network series with mixed
results Anderson decamped to CBS for the
family sitcom Dave's World a
fictionalized take on the life of
newspaper columnist and author Dave
Berry post also moved to CBS partnering
with John Ritter for the political
sitcom hearts of fire the most
successful of these critically if not
commercially was the John leroquette
show which ran for Four Seasons on NBC
larocet starred as John Hemingway a
recovering alcoholic who works the night
shift at a St Louis bus terminal while
it's set up for similarities to Night
Court the show is much closer to a
dramedy or even a weekly Short play
particularly in its darker season 1.
despite Emmy nominations for laroquet
and co-star Liz Torres in its first
three seasons the show is never a
popular success and was abruptly
canceled part way through its fourth
season several episodes were never aired
until released for syndication years
later
for fans of Tina Fey's legendary sitcom
30 Rock it must be both validating and
depressing that so many of the show's
Showbiz jokes have become real life
things since the show ended in 2013. the
2023 Night Court Revival could be added
to that list as well except for the fact
that 30 Rock didn't just joke about a
reunion it actually made it happen sort
of season three's the one with the cast
of Night Court sees Kenneth the NBC page
despondent over the Page's new uniforms
to cheer him up show within a show star
Tracy Jordan gathers the cast of Night
Court in order for Kenneth to shoot his
unauthorized and probably illegal script
for a more satisfying series finale
however Kenneth's plans to give Harry
and Christine a proper courthouse
wedding go awry when the actors fall
back into the same 15 year old
jealousies and arguments when the Night
Court sequel series was announced in
2021 fans were Justified and wondering
not only who from the original cast
might return but who from the original
cast was still alive to return the
series suffered two notable deaths while
it was still on the air original bailiff
Selma Diamond died after the first
season in 1985 only for her replacement
actress Florence hell up to die after
the second season a year later after
Dave's world ended in 1997 Anderson
stepped away from the Limelight opening
a jazz club in New Orleans where he
performed Comedy and Magic he took just
a handful of on-camera roles in the
years that followed on shows like son of
the beach in 2018 Anderson died from a
stroke in his North Carolina home at age
65. then in 2021 both Markie Post and
Charles Robinson passed away like
Anderson Post had stayed away from being
a series regular after the end of Hearts
of fire but had notable roles on Scrubs
and Chicago PD she died after a brief
battle with cancer Robinson was a
celebrated stage actor in addition to
his on-screen work and had performed
with the wire star Wendell Pierce in a
version of James Anthony Tyler's play
some old black man just a few months
before his death from a heart attack the
new Night Court doesn't ignore the loss
of so many of the original cast members
but rather places that lost front and
center in the characters of Abby and Dan
the in-universe death of Harry Stone
hangs over the entire Revival with Abby
using her Night Court Judge ship as a
way to connect with a version of her
father who she never knew
you're Harry's daughter
come in the widowed Dan meanwhile is
more worn out by the length of life in
general age and a great love have sapped
his energy and his shock at Abby's
request for him to return to his old job
is rooted in a very relatable feeling
after they stopped working together he
and Harry fell out of touch and did not
stay friends it's a surprisingly real
comment on the type of thing that Legacy
sequels usually ignore life goes on
after the last episode and the year
spent working in a wacky after hours
arraignment Court end up accounting for
just a brief chapter in that life for
now laroquet is the only returning cast
member from the original series he
anchors a young diverse cast that
includes India de Beaufort as prosecutor
Olivia comedian lacrida as gergs the
bailiff and Kapil talwakar as court
officer Neil and January 2023 Marcia
Warfield gave the new show her blessing
via Twitter though there is no word yet
as to whether she will play Roz once
again Richard Moll meanwhile has
declined to participate presumably bull
is still reaching tall shell elves on
Jupiter
[Music]